♪ ♪
>> Laura: IT HAS TAKEN A WHILE
BUT WE ARE NOW IN THE FINAL 48
HOURS BEFORE I CONFIRMATION VOTE
FOR BRETT KAVANAUGH.
THERE ARE STILL NUMBER OF VOTES
AHEAD.
THE LATEST AND WHERE WE STAND WE
ARE JOINED NOW BY GILLIAN TURNER
AND JULIAN, WHAT ELSE CAN YOU
CALL IT?
>> ALL EYES WERE ON LASER FOCUS
ON THE KEY REPUBLICAN SWING
VOTE.
THAT IS COLLINS MURKOWSKI AND
FLAKE.
SO FAR COLLINS HAS SAID
POSITIVELY ABOUT THE FBI REPORT
BUT SHE SAYS SHE NEEDS MORE
TIME.
SOMETHING IN SHORT SUPPLY THAT
IS CAPITOL HILL TONIGHT.
>> THIS PROCESS HAS BEEN RUINED
BY FEAR AND ANGER AND
UNDERHANDED GAMESMANSHIP FOR TOO
LONG.
IT IS TIME FOR US TO STAND UP
FOR THIS KIND OF THING.
>> THIS IS ABOUT HIJACKING OUR
DEMOCRACY.
I AM ANGRY.
I OWN IT.
>> Laura: EARLIER TONIGHT, A
NEW RANCH IN THE PLAN.
SENATORS RECEIVED THAT THEY
WOULDN'T BE AVAILABLE AT ANY
POINT.
EVEN IF THERE WAS A VOTE FOR
BRETT KAVANAUGH WHO STRONGLY
SUPPORTS.
HE IS IN MONTANA LOCKING HIS
DAUGHTER DOWN THE AISLE.
ORIGINALLY HIS OFFICE TOLD
FOX NEWS WITH THE TIMING OF THE
FBI REPORT THEY COULDN'T AVOID A
POTENTIAL SCHEDULE CONFLICT.
FOX NEWS CAN CONFIRM WE SPOKE
TONIGHT DIRECTLY WITH BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
HIS OFFICE AS HE HAS MADE
ARRANGEMENTS TO BE THERE AND TO
GET HIM ACROSS THE FINISH LINE
AS NEEDED.
WITHOUT DANCE ON THE HILL FOR
THAT POINT, IT WOULD BUY A
CRITICAL FOR McCONNELL.
HE WOULD HAVE TREATED EVERY
SINGLE ONE AND THE 50 REMAINING
REPUBLICANS TO VOTE YES.
THAT IS BEEN FLAKE, MURKOWSKI
AND COLLINS.
THEY WERE TWO OF THOSE THREE.
NOW THE SENATE WILL CONVENE
TOMORROW AT 9:30 A.M. AND RULE
THE PROCEDURAL VOTE AT
10:30 A.M.
THEY HAVE 30 HOURS MAX UNTIL THE
CONFIRMATION VOTE.
IF THEY TAKE ALL OF THAT 30
HOURS, THIS PUTS US AT ABOUT
5:00 P.M. ON SATURDAY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: YEAH.